the jurgen experience you guys you
comedians there must be every once in a
while like a real tragedy to
process that must be very hard yeah i
mean like
it's it's not that common that comedians
take their own lives i mean
it does happen with rob and robin was a
big one for a lot of people because he
was
he was not just a comedian he was like a
cultural icon in terms of like his films
he think all the different movies like i
was in and
he had such a range too that's what you
like to me when you know how
brilliant a person really is like do you
remember that film that he did about the
uh crazy uh film
processing guy it was like 24 hour film
you remember those little film booths
photo booths that people would go to
back in the old days you youngsters we
would have a camera
and the camera would have film in it and
you'd have to bring the film to a place
for processing and robin williams did a
film about a guy who was a psychopath
who was obsessed with someone
from processing their picture one hour
photo that's what it was nice
it was [ __ ] great and you just
from that film you realize the range
this man had right
right you know i mean from goodwill
hunting from you know so many different
yeah he was he's a genius yeah yeah
and the human race is so lucky to have
geniuses in it you know what i mean like
we all feed off them
yeah we do we get we they elevate us and
it costs them sometimes but we
all need we need those people you know
yeah to be a guy like that to be
just dealing with the kind of rpms he
was dealing with
yeah you know like it he would spit out
these amazing
works but you know just a cost on
himself
you know good good morning vietnam in
the in the initials
you know a few minutes like it's pretty
clear that it wasn't scripted because
the p
you know there's this like kid in the
control booth i mean the conceit is that
as a
it's a military dj and a radio announcer
during vietnam
right and and uh the military command
didn't really like him because he was
saying things that were sort of like
not not sufficiently sort of respectful
of the war or whatever but of course the
troops loved them
he was a real guy right and so robin
williams it was
pretty clear if you watch the beginning
it's worth watching it that he
that it wasn't scripted because the kid
in the in the sound booth behind him you
could watch him react
to this like three minute like the
outpouring from robin williams where
he's like channeling different people
and it's all coming out it's totally
insane
yeah and this kid can't even stand up
he's laughing so hard i'm like that's
not acting
right that's a guy yes he actually
hasn't had no idea this was coming right
right right it's amazing
yeah i met him only once and i met him
after one of my shows
i didn't know i was talking to him until
a couple minutes into the conversation
he had a crazy big white beard and he
waited in line with everybody else to
meet me
and uh i was talking to him he was
telling i was telling oh i love this bit
i love that and i love how you put that
together i was like oh thanks man things
are pretty
i'm like holy [ __ ] this is robin
williams
i got i didn't know i literally had no
idea until like several minutes into our
conversation
he must have loved that that was pretty
cool man yeah very cool
it was cool that you know he first of
all was cool that he just
went to the show by himself right you
know he
decided he wanted to come see me maybe
somebody told him i was funny and he
came to
and then he waited in line to meet me
and then wanted to talk about individual
bits and how he loved how i put this one
together and that one
but it was crazy it was like i realized
in the middle of it i'm like oh my god
that's awesome
it was it was was pretty wild but that
just shows you what kind of
thoughtful person he was you know he
wasn't
into being seen in fact he had a
baseball hat on and glasses and his
crazy big white bushy beard
couldn't even recognize him right he's
snuck around
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between
video and audio experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience